vous savez comment ça va oui c'est quoi
le sujet d'aujourd'hui à les règles ben
quoi
ben c'est dégueulasse banon ben si banon
ben si banon ben si pourquoi ben si
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui on va parler des règles
parce qu'on va pas se mentir on entend
dire tout et n'importe quoi sur ce sujet
comme sur pas mal d'autres
avant de commencer je tiens à faire un
petit disque les moeurs comme on dit sur
internet
si on est en l'an 2000 dtcc une chaîne
de vulgarisation donc l'idée c'est de
simplifier les choses et de parler des
cas les plus courants pour les rendre
accessibles au plus grand nombre
mais quand je vais parler des femmes et
des règles gardez bien à l'esprit que
les choses ne sont pas aussi binaire
toutes les femmes n'ont pas leurs règles
et toutes les personnes qui ont leurs
règles ne sont pas des femmes
alors pour plein de raisons et notamment
dans le cas des personnes transgenres
qui méritent évidemment une vidéo dédiée
en attendant pour le sujet du jour je
vous renvoie aux liens que je vous ai
mis dans la description
cette précision est en fait je vous
propose maintenant de démonter quelques
mythes et quelques mito sur les
menstruations des règles des talents
puisque c'est précieux alors non ce
n'est pas sale mais on va détailler un
peu quand même
les règles c'est le résultat visible du
cycle menstruel que les personnes qui
possèdent un utérus connaissent entre la
puberté et la ménopause
en gros le corps se prépare
régulièrement d'où le nom à une
éventuelle fécondation et il passe par
plusieurs phases
il se passe plein de choses notamment au
niveau des hormones mais aussi de la
paroi de l'utérus qui s'épaissit et qui
se prépare au cas où elle aurait besoin
d'accueillir un petit pensionnaire
et si finalement personne ne vient
s'installer on laisse tomber on nettoie
tout jusqu'à la prochaine fois
du coup la couche superficielle de
l'endomètre la muqueuse qui tapissent
l'intérieur de l'utérus
elle se décolle ça saigne un peu et tout
ça est évacuée par le vagin bon mais
alors du coup est-ce que c'est sale y'a
quoi là dedans bas du sens donc de la
muqueuse
c'est à dire une espèce de pot et des
trucs récupérer sur le trajet genre la
flore chargé de défendre le vagin contre
les infections à dire que les bactéries
ok mais des bactéries vous en avais un
peu partout sur la peau pour vous
protéger celle là elles sont pas plus
méchante que les autres et règles ou
pareil
elles sont là tout le temps et
d'habitude ça dérange pas trop les gens
qui rentrent en contact avec donc rien
de salade
s'il vous plaît à j'ai l'impression que
notre monstre urologue jack parker veut
intervenir alors non seulement c'est pas
sale mais en plus vu l'endroit où ça se
trouve personne ne vous force à aller
voir ça va pas vous sauter à la gorge
les règles alors non en tout cas
beaucoup moins que ce qu'on pense et il
ya des moyens pour empêcher ça de base
le sang menstruel
oui parce que les règles ça s'appelle
les menstruations et le sans faute
appelle les monstrueux le sang menstruel
donc il à son odeur mais ils sont pas
mauvais sauf s'il est pas frais mais ça
c'est comme tout c'est comme la
transpiration de base ça sans rien mais
si sam acer façon un peu le sens qui
stagne d'où qu'ils viennent
ça sent si on ajoute à ça les substances
rejetées par les bactéries qui en
profitent que ça stagne pour proliférer
et les produits contenus dans les
protections si on garde tout ça un peu
longtemps
ça sent encore une fois on est d'accord
même dans ces cas là c'est discret et
toute personne qui se tient une distance
socialement acceptable de la culotte
concernés n'a aucune idée de ce qui s'y
passe mais peut-être que jack parker à
un conseil oui n'avez-vous normalement
trop ça a tendance à aggraver les choses
et surtout changer de protection toutes
les 3 à 4 heures en moyenne sauf la
niche évidemment quand on a des règles
on n'en fut partout alors les règles
c'est 3 à 5 jours tous les 28 jours
mais ok c'est pas aussi régulier que son
nom pourrait le laisser penser
ça peut être plus ça peut être moins
selon les personnes mais surtout ça peut
être irréguliers du coup oui dans
l'absolu ça peut arriver sans prévenir
mais il ya quand même quelques signes
avant coureurs qui font que en général
on anticipe un petit peu le coup et puis
surtout on n'en fout pas partout parce
qu'en moyenne la quantité de sang qui
s'écoule ses 35 à 50 millilitres sur
toute la durée des règles on parle de
règles abondantes
à partir de 80 mm 35 à 50 millilitres ça
fait entre 7 et 10 cuillères à café
voilà 10 cuillères à café ça fait ça
étalé sur plusieurs jours
y'a pas de quoi atteindre une pièce non
plus hein donc non avoir ses règles ça
ne veut pas dire se transformer en un
geyser 200 incontrôlable et la sûreté
des protections hygiéniques adaptés aux
différents flux une fois qu'on a trouvé
celles qui conviennent sauf accident ça
ne devrait pas poser problème
les femmes sont chiantes floraison leurs
règles alors essayons de voir les choses
de façon à la fois concrète et objective
le cycle menstruel entraînent des
variations hormonales importante la
progestérone par exemple elles
augmentent puis elles chutent
brutalement juste avant les règles ce
qui peut avoir des répercussions sur
l'humeur donc sur le moral un peu comme
après un accouchement
il peut y avoir aussi toute une batterie
de répercussions physiques qui font que
ça n'est pas précisément le moment le
plus confortable du moins le syndrome
prémenstruel apparaît plusieurs jours
avant les règles avec son cortège de
symptômes comme des douleurs abdominales
dans le dos ou dans les seins des
troubles digestifs de la fatigue des
problèmes de peau des troubles du
sommeil des maux de tête des bouffées de
chaleur etc
en théorie tout ça ça disparaît plus ou
moins au moment de l'arrivée des
menstruations mais ça laisse sa place
aux diverses sensations liées aux flux
ça c'est la raison pour laquelle les
personnes qui ont ou qui vont avoir
leurs règles ne se sentent pas forcément
au mieux les troupes sont plus ou moins
fort selon les individus mais attention
se sentir mal ça n'est pas être chiant
ou chiante
d'abord parce que ça c'est un jugement
et ensuite parce que ça implique des
relations un don des interactions avec
d'autres personnes
en l'occurrence ce qui est sûr c'est que
dans tous les cas un peu d'empathie ça
fait jamais de mal
al'inverse les allusions répétées et
plus ou moins fines aux règles et à
l'état nerveux ça n'aide pas vraiment
donc non les personnes qui ont leurs
règles ne sont pas chiante elles sont
justes potentiellement en train de
morfler soyez aussi cool avec elle
qu'avec une personne coréenne rage de
dents par exemple un pass campus la fait
tous les mois à et aussi ne mettez pas
tout si on compte des règles si une
personne vous envoie chier c'est
peut-être parce qu'elle supporte moins
bien les trucs pénible que d'habitude
mais c'est peut-être aussi parce que les
troupes énigmes assez pénible justement
avoir des rapports sexuels pendant les
règles et dangereux bon alors là soyons
clairs non pas du tout on l'a déjà vu
les menstrues c'est pas sale est ce
qu'on trouve à l'intérieur s'est pas
fondamentalement différent de ce qu'il
ya dans le secteur d'habitude alors ok
il ya du sang en plus
et quand on pense au sens on pense aux
maladies sexuellement transmissibles
mais en réalité ça change absolument
rien à la situation soit on est dans le
cas d'un couple et les deux partenaires
ont fait leur dépistage tout est clean
auquel cas pas de problème soit les deux
partenaires quels qu'ils soient ne sont
pas dépistés et la règle ou pas règles
on se protège donc ça changerait en plus
niveau quantité de sang on l'a vu on est
loin du desus donc pour l'hygiène je
vous laisse voir c'est entre vous juste
si la protection et à l'intérieur du
vagin genre tampon voile cup éponge et
ses petits conseils retirer la juste
avant tout ce qui est pénétration c'est
quand même mieux donc médicalement
parlant on peut avoir des rapports
sexuels pendant les règles sans problème
ça n'est ni dangereux ni salle c'est
chacun son choix quand on veut comme on
veut et on a le droit de changer d'avis
d'un cycle à l'autre ou d'un jour à
l'autre
voilà je crois qu'on a vu le principal
mais juste pour être sûr d'avoir
vraiment fait le tour des boutiques non
le sens des règles mais pas bleu malgré
ce que la pub et c'est de vous faire
croire oui on peut préparer de la
mayonnaise quand on a ses règles
sauf si on est nul en cuisine comme moi
mais ça c'est un autre problème
en tout cas ça empêche pas la mayonnaise
de monter à ce ça fait pas tourner le
lait nous et ça transforme pas le vent
au vinaigre
voilà on a démonté quelques mythes et
quelques mito sur les règles
pour le reste je vous renvoie au livre
de jack parker et à son blog passion
dans ce truc dont je vous ai les
références dans la description de cette
vidéo voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui
pas de panique on revient très vite pour
de nouvelles vidéos
aux 10 il a écouté mettez vous bien et
puis surtout portez vous bien je peux
pas vous dire à chaque fois
[Musique]